let's talk about the
optics of status and how that creates
the
uh impression of high value when i say
impression it's not illusion it's it's
certainly the impression so
why is status that important yeah so we
did a course um before this called dms
on demand
we walked guys through a to z how to
build an instagram page to
attract and um get responses from
females and not be left on scene
and the main thing is that like you're
creating a perception around yourself of
who you are
now here's the problem though uh if
you're creating our perception and
that's not who you really are
then once you go missing person you're
not congruent
so this this course we're doing now high
value um academy basically
is where we're taking the uh behind the
scenes person
and actually turning them into that high
value individual so basically
it's one thing to be have presence
online and fake it
that's one thing but actually that
person off camera is legit
like that's that's when you're a true
like i would say top percent guy because
not only are you presenting yourself as
a brand online
but you're that person in person as well
so i would say regarding status
if you can showcase yourself online
let's say for example you're like a top
painter or like you're your artist right
you put your your art up on instagram
you put it on social media
and it's you with a cool background you
doing your thing that's displaying high
value to certain
uh niche people also as well let's say
for example you're into cars right
uh let's let's be real here girls like
to be in bus cars or nice cars so
you just play that lifestyle and you're
showing yourself off as that person that
is always around cars you live a certain
lifestyle and that alone can get you
like attract things to you now i'll say
this regarding status and clout
nowadays with these young girls bro
that's all they really care about
so you could be broke you could be you
could be like you know i'm saying
um down to zero but if you look the part
they'll come to you yeah but here's the
thing we all know uh
when you smash a girl when you when you
have fun whatever what's next
that's it you don't get anything from it
right so guess what
if you become that that person that's
high value uh behind the scenes and
you're congruent with that
and you have the online presence you're
gonna kill it yeah and also i would say
with status you also um besides your
lifestyle the men you surround yourself
also
is a testament to your status like if
you guys have seen our show
we've been able to bring in you know q
banks arm plug uh
stunt lifestyle like a bunch of big
movers here in miami you know what i'm
saying and we're also in the talks with
some other guys
uh to get them on the show but um once
you have a certain status you deal with
certain people it opens other doors
where guys are gonna be like oh you
dealt with him
that makes you that i trust you i trust
you it's credibility what i'm saying is
credibility so like
just from when we did our first
interview from with q right and cue
shout out to him at cube banks he's one
of the top forex traders in the world
you know what i mean and he basically
makes millions of dollars and drives
nice cars all other stuff
everyone knows him in miami with the
yellow lambo so when he came on our show
it opened doors for other people to say
yo you know we want to do an interview
with you too you know we did an
interview with rafael vargas yeah uh you
know greg for a bunch of like big names
here
but um aligning yourself with like uh
guys that have status like that also
speaks a lot to your status because
they're not gonna work with you and we
all know men you know especially guys of
higher status
don't necessarily associate with other
men unless they feel like they're at
least a peer
or on the way to get there so um us
bringing them on the show
shows an enormous uh social proof and
then that also is extremely attractive
to women because i always say your
network is your net worth yep
yeah that's one of the biggest mistakes
i see a lot of guys making is they waste
their time
in rooms where they're the smartest guy
in the room you need to put yourself in
more rooms where you're not the smartest
guy in the room
um that opens a lot of doors for you but
some guys struggle with um
you know letting go parts parts of their
lives that
they're attached to like friendships
that they've held on to for a number of
years because we hung out in high school
uh i see men and women doing this in
fact it's not just dudes but
um yeah like you have to be
you have to be ruthless with your time
and not ruthless in like an [ __ ] kind
of way
but there's certain people that are
going to hold you back you know i
describe
anchors and sales right you know when
the wind feels fills your sails it
it brings your boat to the next port of
call anchors hold you back and you have
to learn how to cut anchors from your
life
social status will improve by osmosis
when you spend more time in rooms where
you're not the smartest guy in the room
like
one of the things that you'll notice
about joe rogan and what helped him grow
his
podcast and exposure to people was
i mean he doesn't do it so much today
but he would almost always take pictures
with him and his guest and post it onto
instagram or post it onto twitter now
right he doesn't do that so much now
because he's already gained that status
and he's got the cred but
you know when you have these big names
showing up and
and they're willing to contribute two or
three hours of their time to your
podcast
production and you get you know a
picture with them they're on your show
and then you start to develop that
relationship you know they come back you
know to your show at a later date maybe
you go on their show if they have
something that they're hosting
you get doors open to comedy events you
get doors open to netflix specials you
get doors
you just get doors open right so status
is something that takes some time to
build but
you can't sleepwalk into being a high
status guy you have to make
incremental choices on a daily basis
that will
allow your status to improve right it
doesn't happen
you know just overnight and it doesn't
happen if you're not paying attention to
it
you